>> Jeanine: IT'S MAKE OR BREAK
TIME FOR BOTH PARTIES ON THE EVE
OF THE CRITICAL MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
WE'RE JUST HOURS AWAY FROM
VOTERS CASTING THEIR BALLOTS TO
DETERMINE THE FUTURE OF AMERICA.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE TO
TURN THE TIDE AND WIN OVER LAST
MINUTE VOTERS.
BUT PRESIDENT BIDEN JUST SCREWED
UP BIG TIME WITH ANOTHER OUT OF
TOUCH REMARK.
>> NO MORE DRILLING.
THERE IS NO MORE DRILLING!
I HAVEN'T FORMED ANY NEW
DRILLING.
THAT WAS BEFORE I WAS PRESIDENT.
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK ON THAT.
GET THAT DONE.
>> Jeanine: THAT COMES JUST TWO
DAYS AFTER THE PRESIDENT SAYS HE
WANTS TO SHUT DOWN EVERY COAL
PLANT IN AMERICA.
THE WHITE HOUSE STILL TRYING TO
SPIN THAT ONE AWAY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT DONE
WITH FOOLISH COMMENTS.
THEIR SOLUTION TO AMERICANS
STRUGGLING WITH 40-YEAR HIGH
INFLATION IS TO EAT CHEF
BOYARDE.
>> WHAT DO YOU PLAN TO DO TO
HELP SOLVE OUR INFLATION
PROBLEM?
>> YEAH, I GREW UP IN A FAMILY
WHERE IF THE GAS PRICE WENT UP,
THE FOOD BUDGET WENT DOWN.
SO BY THIS TIME OF WEEK, WE'D BE
EATING CHEF BOYARDE IF THAT
BUDGET WASN'T GOING TO CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT FAMILIES HAVE TO DO.
>> Jeanine: AND WITH COMMENTS
LIKE THAT, IT'S NO WONDER
DEMOCRATS STRATEGISTS ARE MAKING
DIRE PREDICTIONS LIKE THIS.
>> I'M A LOYAL DEMOCRAT, BUT I
AM NOT HAPPY.
I JUST THINK THAT WE ARE, YOU
KNOW, WE DID NOT LISTEN TO
VOTERS IN THIS ELECTION, AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A BAD
NIGHT.
WHEN VOTERS TELL YOU OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT THEY CARE MOSTLY
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, LISTEN TO
THEM!
STOP TALKING ABOUT DEMOCRACY
BEING AT STAKE.
>> Jeanine: OK, SO WHAT WE'VE
GOT NOW, GREG, IS A PRESIDENT
WHO COMES OUT AND SAYS I'M GOING
TO SHUT DOWN THE COAL MINES!
AND THEN COMES OUT AND SAYS THE
TRUTH IS I AM NOT GOING -- OR
THE PRESIDENT'S WORDS WERE
TWISTED AND THEN HE COMES OUT
TODAY, THEY LET HIM OUT AGAIN.
AND HE DECIDES THAT HE'S GOING
TO SAY THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
ANY DRILLING.
WHY DID THEY LET HIM OUT?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
I WANT TO SAY I -- I'M SO
EXCITED.
WE ARE A DAY AWAY FROM THE END
OF DEMOCRACY.
AND I HAVE BEEN PUTTING ALL OF
MY ENERGY INTO DESTROYING THIS
INCREDIBLY FRAGILE SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DID TODAY?
I PUT UP FLYERS OVER MY
NEIGHBORHOOD SAYING THE ELECTION
WAS CANCELED AND THEN I SET UP A
VOTER REGISTRATION BOOTH AT
N.Y.U. AND I TOOK ALL THEIR
INFORMATION AND I THREW IT IN
THE EAST RIVER.
ANYWAY, I GET IT FROM JOE BIDEN
HE DOESN'T CARE WHAT HE SAYS.
THERE'S TWO KINDS OF LIES THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST EIGHT --
FOUR TO SIX YEARS.
WHEN TRUMP FIBBED, IT WAS ALWAYS
A SALESMAN FIB.
IT WAS LIKE TRYING TO GET YOU
PAST THE SALE.
YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE THIS.
IT'S GOING TO BE SO GREAT!
YOU'RE GOING TO BE BORED WITH
WINNING.
THAT WAS HIS LIE.
IT WAS AN EXAGGERATION OF AN
AFFIRMATION.
WITH BIDEN, HE CAN -- IT'S A
POLITICAL LIE.
HE CAN CONTRADICT THE VERY SAME
THING HE SAID BEFORE.
HE CAN DEMAND THE OIL COMPANIES
THAT THEY STEP UP DRILLING.
AND THEN IN THE NEXT BREATH SAY
THERE'S NO DRILLING BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T BELIEVE IN ANYTHING HE
SAYS.
HE'S BEEN IN POLITICS FOR SO
LONG THAT WORDS DON'T MATTER!
HE ASSUMES THAT WE ALL HAVE
TINY, TINY ATTENTION SPANS AND
THAT HE CAN SAY WHATEVER HE
WANTS.
AND THEN YOU GOT THIS GUY
TALKING ABOUT CHEF BOYARDEE.
IS THAT WHAT IT IS?
LOVE THAT STUFF.
BY THE WAY, CHEAP FOOD IS GREAT.
HOW LONG BEFORE THE SQUAD SAYS,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT PURINA CAT CHOW WITH A
LITTLE WATER, IT CAN GO A LONG
WAY WITH A FAMILY OF FOUR.
>> Jeanine: DANA, THE WHOLE IDEA
OF SHAWN PATRICK MALONY IN
HUDSON VALLEY WILL LOSE TO MIKE
LAWLER, STATE ASSEMBLYMAN.
THIS GUY IS HEAD OF THE DCCC.
WHEN THINGS ARE TOUGH, WE EAT
CHEF BOYARDEE.
HE SAID MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO START EATING CHEF BOYARDEE.
HOW CLUELESS ARE THESE
DEMOCRATS?
>> Dana: IF YOU COULD PUT THE
ENTIRE ELECTION CYCLE INTO ONE
CLIP, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN THIS
ONE ABOUT CHEF BOYARDEE.
BECAUSE HE IS IN CHARGE OF
GETTING OTHER DEMOCRATS ELECTED.
THIS ELECTION IS ABOUT THE
INFLATION AND THE ECONOMY.
AND ALSO, BECAUSE VOTERS KEEP
SAYING, I DON'T FEEL THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT
ACTUALLY CARES ABOUT WHAT I CARE
ABOUT.
AND NOT ONLY DID HE SAY TO EAT
CHEF BOYARDEE.
LET'S GO BACK A LITTLE BIT.
REMEMBER JOHN KERRY TOLD ENERGY
WORKERS JUST GET A GREEN JOB.
THEY SAID OH, GAS IS HIGH.
BUY AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
THAT WAS FROM MAYOR PETE.
THEY SAID LOOK AT MY LITTLE
NOTES HERE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY WANT TO LET THEM BIKE TO
WORK, PUT ON A SWEATER,
BASICALLY, BECAUSE HEATING OIL
WILL BE SO HIGH.
IT'S NOT JUST PRESIDENT BIDEN
THAT HAS SAID THIS, THIS IS LIKE
A STRATEGY WHICH IS WHY HILLARY
ROSEN, A LONG TIME DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST IS SAYING WOW, WE ARE
IN BAD SHAPE.
>> Jeanine: YEAH, TRUTH IS,
JESSICA, THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
NOW RECOGNIZING THAT THEY'RE IN
BAD SHAPE, IN TERRIBLE SHAPE.
WE HEARD IT IN THE ORIGINAL
SOUND, HILLARY ROSEN BEING
ANOTHER PERSON.
AND NOW, FETTERMAN TODAY IS
TALKING ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
WHY ALL OF A SUDDEN ARE THEY NOW
LISTENING?
WHY WERE THEY TALKING ABOUT
EVERYTHING ELSE?
>> Jessica: IT'S BEEN A FEW
WEEKS, BASICALLY SINCE THE TURN
ON THE DECISION WHERE THAT WAS
THE THIRD OR FOURTH MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT SHIFTED
OVER TO CRIME.
AND PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
JOBS AND THE ECONOMY AND
INFLATION AS ITS OWN ISSUE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
IT'S A LITTLE LATE.
I THINK HILLARY ROSEN MAY BE TOO
FAR INTO THE DOOM AND GLOOM.
I LOOKED BACK ON WHAT THE USUAL
NUMBER OF HOUSE SEATS THAT ARE
LOST IN A MIDTERM ELECTION IS.
IT'S 27.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Dana: WHERE ARE YOU STARTING
FROM?
I KNOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS GOING
TO TRY TO SPIN IT THAT WAY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S RIGHT.
>> Jessica: EVERYBODY IS GOING
TO VOTE TOMORROW.
MAYBE YOU ALREADY HAVE.
I ALREADY HAVE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
THIS IS NOT -- PEOPLE ARE
PARTISANS TODAY, EVEN
INDEPENDENTS ARE PARTISANS TO
SOME DEGREE.
>> Jeanine: HILLARY ROSEN ISN'T
PARTISAN.
>> Jessica: YES, SHE IS.
SHE'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PARTISANS IN AMERICA.
SHE'S PAID TO BE PARTISAN.
>> Jeanine: SHE'S RECOGNIZING
THAT THE DEMOCRAT ARE NOT
LISTENING AND THAT WILL -->>
Jessica: I'VE SAID THAT MYSELF.
WE ALSO MUST NOTE WHICH WE DO
EVERY TIME WE TALK ABOUT
ELECTIONS, DEMOCRATS ARE
PROVERBIAL BED WETTERS WHEN IT
COMES TO ELECTIONS.
WE COMPLETELY FLIP UP.
I WANT TO WAIT UNTIL WHAT THE
ELECTION DOES.
>> Jeanine: 80% OF AMERICA
THINKS WE'RE HEADED IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, OK, THAT'S A GIVEN.
NOW, 49%, 47% BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED A GREAT DEAL OF CHANGE.
AND THEN 19% THINKS QUITE A BIT
OF CHANGE.
SO THE WAY I FIGURE THAT IS
ALMOST 60% ARE LIKE DRASTIC
CHANGE.
HOW WILL THAT TRANSLATE
TOMORROW?
>> Jesse: IF YOU'RE ON MSNBC
ANCHOR, THOSE POLLS ARE RIGGED
YOU AND CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT THE
PEOPLE WILL TELL YOU.
YOU'LL SEE A MASSIVE WAVE
TOMORROW.
AND IT'S BEEN BUILDING FOR A
VERY, VERY LONG TIME AND I DON'T
CARE IF I'M RAISING
EXPECTATIONS.
I'M SPEAKING FROM THE HEART.
AND YOU CAN FEEL IT.
>> Jeanine: YOU DON'T HAVE A
HEART!
>> Jesse: I PRETEND NOT TO HAVE
A HEART TO COME OFF AS COOL.
I'M ACTUALLY MUCH MORE
COMPASSIONATE THAN YOU ARE,
GREG!
WHEN YOU SEE JOE BIDEN SAY THAT,
THAT'S WHY JOE BIDEN GOT LUCKY
IN 2020 BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE
TO CAMPAIGN BECAUSE OF COVID.
WHEN JOE GOES OUT AND CAMPAIGNS,
HE STICKS HIS FOOT IN HIS MOUTH
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
AND WHAT HE DID THERE IS THEY
HAD A WHOLE ARGUMENT FOR A YEAR
ABOUT WHO TO BLAME FOR HIGH GAS
PRICES.
THEY HAD PUTIN.
THEY HAD LENNY.
THAT OWNED THE CORNER GAS
STATION.
EXXON MOBILE.
IF YOU'RE NOT USING UP YOUR
LEASES AND HE TAKES A HAND
GRENADE AND THROWS IT OUT THERE
AND SAYS I'M THE ONE THAT'S NOT
APPROVING NEW DRILLING AND BLOWS
IT UP RIGHT THERE.
WE EXPECT POLITICIANS TO LIE.
THAT'S A GIVEN.
BUT WE EXPECT THEM TO KEEP TRACK
OF THEIR OWN LIES.
THEN THERE'S CHEF BOYARDEE GUY,
HEAD OF DCCC, SUPPOSED TO BE THE
SMART ONE.
NOT SUPPOSED TO COME OUT AND
MAKE A GAFFE LIKE THAT.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING ALMOST A YEAR
TO HEAR WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
SUPPOSED ON SAY ABOUT INFLATION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
SAY?
EAT CHEF BOYARDEE.
THAT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO ABOUT
INFLATION AND HERE'S HOW.
THIS IS WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN.
YOU DEAL WITH INFLATION.
YOU EAT CHEAP SLOP.
SAME THING THEY SAID WITH CRIME,
REMEMBER?
WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN TO REDUCE
CRIME.
JUST POP OUT YOUR EAR PLUGS IN
THE SUBWAY SO YOU CAN SEE THE
CRIMINALS COMING AT YOU.
AND THEN THE OTHER WOMAN SAYS,
YOU KNOW, DEMOCRACY IS UNDER
SIEGE.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
DEMOCRATS NOT REPRESENTING THEIR
OWN PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THREAT.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO GO OUT THERE
AND REPRESENT THE PEOPLE.
IT'S A REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY.
IMAGINE AFTER 9/11, GEORGE W.
BUSH CAME OUT AND CAMPAIGNED IN
THAT MIDTERM ON ENTITLEMENT
REFORM.
AND THE COUNTRY IS DYING TO TALK
ABOUT TERRORISM AND HE'S LIKE
NO, LET'S GO WITH ENTITLEMENT
REFORM.
THAT'S WHAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING.
THE TWO BIGGEST ISSUES, CRIME
AND INFLATION.
THEY'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> Jeanine: OK.
UP NEXT, DEMOCRATS SAY IF YOU
VO